you have done so many things through
your career besides Leo if someone has
never seen anything you've done it's the
first thing you want them watching and
why oh I would say probably oh God
that's a tough one I mean covers so many
different kinds of Comedy you know I
mean the Star Wars Triumph visit is so
it's Bliss to me because it's like he's
making fun of these kids but they are
totally in on it you know not that not
they're in on the joke but they're
they're game for it so it's such a happy
11 minutes of Comedy oh I've watched
that 11 minutes a number of times I
actually want to ask you because you
you're Fearless when you do stuff like
that and what what's the most nervous
you were when doing Triumph recording
one of those bits okay I can tell you it
was probably when I went to Texas to
cover Ted Cruz and bet or work just
because um you know over the past 15
years uh the world's just gotten tenser
and tenser and more polarized and Texas
is very light with I mean just to be
very Frank you know you just get
paranoid and like I had been to the
Trump
inauguration and I that was the first
time I'd really like doing the same
thing I always do but now there are a
couple of people aggressively like
tearing my tearing the cigar out of
Triumph's mouth one motorcycle guy one
biker was like get the out of here
man get out of my face like that
kind of thought and then another Biker's
like okay buddy calm down calm down he's
cool he's cool and then so I went to
Texas and I thought oh man just one
crazy person I was scared and but but
once you're there people are just people
and they're not you know everything is
everything is heightened on CNN or these
places everybody they always show you
the craziest person because that's what
gets attention sure they do it in every
story um and you know even with with
everything it just you see the the most
extreme because that's what gets the
clicks and that what's gets and so it
makes people even more drawn apart from
each other to see the
world you know displayed that way
jumping into why I get to talk to you
yeah switching completely gears uh I
really I am a comedian by way sorry I I
really enjoyed this movie and one of the
things that I really enjoyed is that
like there's a lot of message this movie
but it's a sweet delivery it's like a
brownie you don't realize you're getting
broccoli inside so can you talk about
that aspect the kids are going to learn
and you know what I mean yeah I hope it
kind of sneaks up on kids because it's
just kind of funny at first oh this
crazy lizard is caught and he's talking
and then he's having this conversation
and this girl's confessing that she
talks too fast but she doesn't realize
she's talking too fast as she's talking
about talking too fast and singing about
it and I feel like you know all these
subjects are funny writing a Dear John
Letter to your drone or uh you know
they're just inherently silly and
playful but at the same time the message
starts creeping up on you that these
kids are really starting to get
something out of having someone to share
their fears with and uh they haven't had
that I know I didn't and it would have
helped a lot if I had felt comfortable
enough to you know because your parents
are the best but you just kids aren't
ready to do that most of the time and uh
and I didn't I didn't do it with my
friends really and and I would have
loved to I think I would have been a
happier kid I was pretty happy anyway
because I was funny and I just got I
kind of skated by just by making people
laugh and making myself laugh did you
ever think because the the Drone thing I
found I found very funny but it's it's
over the toop compared to a lot of the
other stuff were you ever did anyone
ever said maybe this does this work or
were you always like oh no this is funny
uh I got a lot of push back on the
dancing
stopwatches sometimes it was storyboard
artists who get into these animation
rules like okay you know uh maybe the
animals talk here but shouldn't these
kind of animals not talk or and now this
is just bridge too far I'm sorry dancing
stopwatches I mean this is a break from
reality but just and I'm like it's an
animated movie we can do anything we
want and I just don't you know but we
actually like cut that down a little bit
cuz then the net work the Netflix people
also were like that's just you know
people don't like it and there were some
people in the audience on test
screenings that hated the dancing
stopwatches but not a lot like I mean
the movie got great numbers but there
are a few people who don't like it so
it's like really it's like five out of a
hundred people but we did trim it down a
little bit but it still works it's still
there that I'm always curious about the
editing process so how did the film
change in the editing room in ways you
guys didn't expect it really um it
really didn't change that much other
than just it was a very
long we got it down to 91 minutes before
credits which is pretty standard you
know and and I was thinking it should be
96 because that's what Moana was I
thought oh a musical you got to tell the
story and have songs but but we managed
and I
mean biggest struggle was the third act
which is a very common thing in movie
right and we
just we just um you know tried different
things and I don't know I'm sorry I
don't have a better answer on no it's
fine yeah uh I want to switch back to
something else you did uh which is TV
funh house yeah um I always loved those
when I watched them when I was younger
what's the one and it's a similar
question to the beginning someone has
never seen a TV fun house what's the one
you want them watching oh boy that's
tough
because uh some of them are referential
you know I can just tell tell you some
of my favorites like I mean I love the
idea behind The Ambiguously Gay Duo
because you know the message
was why do we care you know the people
kind of lose sight of that they think
it's a gay joke but it's really about
the villains that's what was funny about
it to me why are they so obsessed with
whether these guys you know have sex or
not it's like they're superheroes
they're they're the ultimate Heroes on
Earth and people are wasting their time
thinking about that so I love that
concept and I always will and then you
know uh there was one where Mr T I guess
you know and then there's the Christmas
one with Jesus I I I got too many of
them God damn yeah and so many of them
are so funny which is why I'm saying
thank you for your work and for making
me laugh for so many years and I really
wish this is I hope this is a huge hit
for you and everyone involved thank you
I'm very proud of it means a lot to me
that it has that kind of silliness and a
and a and a very simple human message to
it